let's talk about The Hangover Part Two
you you shot this movie in Bangkok the
minute you hear of the idea that The
Hangover 2 was in Bangkok you think the
possibilities are endless you really
went there what did you see because I've
always heard it's an incredibly sinful
City I'm just curious what's the what's
the craziest thing that you saw I love
when you asked me that your eyes are
like it's I'm very repressed
I don't get out at all what did you see
I need to live vicariously through you
uh what is it you saw uh uh I saw God I
saw some weird stuff
um I saw well first of all you know
remember the first movie they have the
end credits Stills so that's what we saw
the weirdest stuff because we actually
went to all these places and there
weren't any film Crews it's just the
three of us and Todd taking the
photographs the director Todd Phillips
the director yeah took the photos okay
yeah we just sort of run all around
Bangkok and and you know Bangkok is
known for
um these these venues where where
females are able to do things with their
nether regions that um you wouldn't
think they would normally do I love that
you said nether region so well I was
trying to figure out a way to paint the
picture that was fine yeah you don't
have to Poetic actually yeah it's
beautiful yeah thank you
um and uh so there's one gal
uh was able to
um uh eject ping pong balls
um at very at high velocities uh with
the amazing accuracy so I was like I
can't just move on from that
the story just can't flow from there I
just gotta sit with that okay all right
so they can do that
they've got something they could do uh
genetic I don't know what it is yeah uh
if it's if there's a school they go to
I'm not quite sure I didn't ask any
questions right so uh we know major
league baseball finds out go ahead sorry
it's not not appropriate at all and I
apologize to everyone who's watching or
getting a transcript through the courts
so anyway
find out you can
you can be an accident you know
yeah yeah
could be an accident I don't
know Somebody's gotta kill that fly yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
so anyway this woman had this power this
incredible power oh yes yeah and I being
the jackass that I am was like let's do
one where I I you know to the stills of
world sort of watching her do this yes
and I was like oh why don't I do when
I'm like
right in my mouth
[Applause]
record record skips uh handy wipes
coming out from everywhere Ed Helms is
throwing up immediately and by the way
that's not the only thing they do no no
that's enough
but I'm stopping you here before we get
raided you know police are going to come
up from the beach here which is fake
but it was memorable it was memorable
now I think that story has got to be
great for your dating life yeah
so let's start this one girly
I've got a tale of Woe that involves in
other regions
[Applause]